[Musique]
hu
oh
[Musique]
et
oh
ce sens
hélas
et
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
pratique
là
et
[Musique]
toute la forêt donne une réception en
l'honneur de jo le cac
madame la fille est là en grande
toilette jo ayant déclaré que c'était le
plus beau jour de sa vie
le festin commence et les petits nains
ou à la fête champoux le soleil le matin
égratigne chantons bleu soleil
il bataillera michaud tombe l'âge
chantons la douceur de la vie d' alerte
le renard
[Musique]
pourquoi alerte ses jantes il est revenu
à ma réception à ça près de gentil c'est
très gentil mais avant de discuter monde
sur la branche mais tout le monde a fui
ils ont tous en haut de l'arbre cesse de
discuter quel sale habitude montée je
t'expliquerai vite vite elles montrent
le jeune peut plonger trop manger et
puis j'oserais vous avouer que voler
n'est pas mon fort
je suis un oiseau terrestre pic à
l'entêté et vous autres là haut il sait
cet oiseau terrestre au secours ne me
brutaliser pas j'ai peur j'ai le mal de
l'air
or je n'ai jamais pu supporter
l'altitude par une fois que la
supportera l'altitude
nous sommes là pis il me semble que vous
me tutoyez pas d'éléments à jo c'est
l'émotion je vous pardonne mais je ne
pardonne pas mon ascension au jeu le
vertige comme je voulais dit l'altitude
ne vaut rien je veux descendre jamais
pour que le renard vous mange
d'autant qu'il adore les poules je vous
ferai remarquer que je ne suis pas une
poule
disons que pour le renard vous êtes une
grosse poule hélas hélas hélas ne
tombait pas de la branche
voilà la plus grande injure que l'on
puisse me faire aux cette position 1
comme à des temps plus indignes de ma
personne je veux redescendre tient le
renard doit être partie les petits
nation revenus
[Musique]
ah non on descend ou non bon tu es prêt
oui
doucement doucement doucement je le
vertige ouf le volant sécurité sécurité
parlons-en à la ferme j'étais destiné à
la casserole et l'on la forêt où je me
croyais enfin tranquille je suis une
grosse poule pour le renard mourir pour
mourir
je préfère une mort glorieuse clarens
route
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
selon le soleil
[Musique]
ça
oh
je